um that is a game changer right there dang it joel why didn't you tell me about that
before man this is i was thinking about it but we had already moved on
well we're a little light on news topics for this week but i do have some like i don't know in the
doc i have pre-topic shit shooting uh category here and just got a bunch of fun things to talk
about so the first one that i wanted to ask i've actually wanted to ask you this for a couple weeks
how often do you well you're you're pretty you're pretty active in chat right in some of the other
hacker chats that we're in um do you use that more than you use social media do you think
and what kind of role does hacker chats kind of play in your social life uh online yeah 100 i mean like
hacker chats are probably like close to 90 of what i like my what i would consider like my social
circle so like most like i would say 99 of my social circles are like online most of the people
like people that i'm friends with and like close closely acquainted with are not people who i know
like who like live near me like physically near to me um and then day to day like the majority of
people that i talk with are probably hackers and hacker chats i feel like i underused that substantially
because we're in like quite a few little you know hacker chats that we've got together with some
of the other hackers in our in the bug bounty community and like i feel like i'm kind of a ghost
there at least i like i'll go in there and i'll read it from time to time but i'm not like interacting
quite as much and i mean i don't really do that much on social media either but i feel like you know
when i'm ready to just like mindlessly scroll i go to social media and you know scroll through twitter
or something like that instead of like going to the hacker chats and reading you know all you guys
kind of just talking so i think maybe i need to to switch that around a little bit because whenever i
get in there i see you and the guys getting into some pretty cool stuff and i i want to i want to get
in on that yeah i mean i like to just like converse in there i feel like social media is a lot more like
posty so like when i'm using social media it's more for me to like broadcast like publicly that
i'm doing something and if i'm in like the hacker chats it's more like i'm having private conversations
with like people that i trust yeah a lot more than just like random public i definitely do that
for like when i've got a bug and i know someone has some expertise i'll like dm them and like
you know one of the slack channels or like on discord or something but like yeah just just chilling
i think i think that's i think that's an important part of the hacker community that
like i don't know i haven't been i used to be a lot more religious about reading you know all the
different channels and stuff like that but i've just kind of fallen out of it lately since i've been
you know running a little short on time with the rental property and some other things so that's
something yeah man i mean it's really hard to keep up with all of it too there's like a ton of
messages all the time so even i like sometimes i just like i'll see like a bunch of stuff going on
i'm like i don't have time and i'll just use it for like an hour yeah i feel that um solid the other
thing i had here was okay just want to do a clarification because we did an episode a while
back which by the way i'm going to call out our audience on this one let me just pull up the
statistics real quick you all said when i put a post on twitter about what you wanted to see you said that
you wanted to see exclusive techniques and tool releases and our uh rebind multi-a tool release
and browser ssrf uh like episode is like one of the worst performing episodes out there so one you
guys suck two i'm glad you didn't listen to it because i actually made a mistake in there that
somebody messaged in um to info critical thinking podcast.io and corrected me on um this guy cyphron
shot me a shot me a message and said hey by the way the dns rebinding attack that we talk about in
that episode which if you know if you haven't heard it that that bad boy's episode number nine so go check
it out um but i was saying that it mostly only it works for windows only um because of the way the dns
rebinding works like if you're in linux or in mac os it defaults to the private ip address first instead
of the um public ip address but um this guy cypher and messaged me and said hey just fyi um one the
tool you made is completely redundant because ncc group singularity does the same thing and i was like
okay you know what fine but you know maybe there are some features in there that i have that they
don't have or vice versa or whatever but two um we can actually you can use this attack to hit uh local
hostish on um linux and mac os by hitting 0.0.0.0 um yeah so that's pretty cool i mean it's it's it's uh
not necessarily something that you know is going to get you access to an internal um piece there but it's
better than nothing so definitely check that out um set is the target for that rebind uh 0.0.0.0 and
you might be able to hit some internal um apis or something like that if it's sitting behind a reverse
proxy super interesting it's it's very interesting behavior that it would default to like from going
zero to zero to zero to localist exactly and you know you'd think with with linux and mac os you know
by default checking to see if they have you know a private ip address in that dns resolution they would
also think about zero dot zero dot zero but i guess they're not thinking about the reverse proxy
sort of situation yeah that's super super interesting okay dude the other thing i want to
talk about this guy the flipper oh yeah one of these yeah are you serious you had it sitting right in
your desk right in front of you too yeah the flipper um have you set this thing up yet yeah man
i've got mine i've got mine i have a custom firmware on mine okay okay joel all right fine um i just got
mine uh a while back and i haven't had the chance to play around with it yet but i feel like this could
be helpful for the live hacking event that we're doing starting soon um so i'll be bringing mine
yeah i'm gonna get some firmware on this guy and uh and hopefully we'll be able to report back how
exactly it's working hitting some uh bluetooth protocols and yeah it's pretty much only going
to be bluetooth i think for this this event that we're going to go after yeah i mean i would be
surprised if it's doing other stuff especially in like the ranges that the flipper is going to do like
sub gigahertz and stuff but it's always possible i mean sometimes you'll see stuff using like 433
yep so that's that's definitely on the list um the the other thing that i want to talk about
while we were on the topic of bluetooth was i've been playing around in prep for this live hacking
event and if for all of you watching on youtube over my right shoulder there you can see this giant
like just hacker one towel thrown over a bunch of things because sitting under there is the like
absolute crap ton of devices they sent us for this live hacking event um that joel and i are
participating in um coming up towards the end of april and um i realized that i had them sitting
there on that table you know right before this we started recording that may or may not be a giant
blurred out square yeah yeah yeah um hopefully i don't like move my shoulder and like show something
i'm not supposed to show but um yeah i've been playing so one of the one of the devices that we're
targeting sort of has a bluetooth low energy interface i've never done any non-http related hack well like
once or twice i've done some non-http related hacking you know mobile aside and i started playing
around with the better cap uh bluetooth low energy module and that thing is fire um real easy to use
really consistent and i didn't even have to use a um i don't know if this is just the bluetooth chip in my
laptop but i didn't even have to use like uh the uber tooth one or anything like that any external cards
just the in you know the the bluetooth chip built into my laptop was able to enumerate the various
services that i was going after so um definitely definitely check out better caps uh bluetooth low
energy module yeah dude you were showing me that yesterday and i haven't done a ton of bluetooth hacking
either i do mainly either end up on like the network side or maybe i'll like rip a chip and go into like
the source code and stuff but um i had been holding off on buying like an uber tooth or anything like
that for like a while just because i wasn't really sure what i needed and all that kind of stuff and
then i saw that recently a couple months ago they announced that the uber tooth one was being like
retired basically yeah just as i bought it of course i have it on my wish list for like months and months
and months and i was like should i buy this delete yeah so i did some other some other digging and there
were a couple people talking on reddit and stuff that were mentioning the kinds of stuff that they
actually end up using and they had said that they owned the uber tooth but for the most part they don't
end up using it a ton and the basic impression that i got is basically it's like a bluetooth receiver
that's pretty much like it like i don't really know what it does that is extra than that so a lot of
people were were recommending this um this u 100d by cena so this is this is pretty neat um it was like
30 bucks or something it was really not bad and it's apparently it has this crazy crazy range
apparently it can go up to like i want to say like 100 meters or a thousand meters or something
it's like it's really crazy um and i was using that yesterday with uh better cap yeah and it was
working great i can't use it on my mac like through docker or anything for some reason yeah i was gonna
i was curious to see if you got that working yeah it doesn't it doesn't work with the drivers they
they have a note in it somewhere in the documentation that you can't use the ble module with like mac or
windows because it doesn't support like the drivers or something like that i was able to get to work
on my windows through virtual box so if i run it if i run it within an ubuntu vm and i do usb pass
through with the with the adapter it works wait wait so you wait virtual box virtual box on windows
on your windows box you had okay for a second i thought you i thought you had said that you were
on your mac and then you had a windows virtual machine and then you had a ubuntu virtual machine on
that i'm like what the are you doing no i do i have a tube computer i have yeah i have a mac laptop
and a windows pc on the windows pc i was running ubuntu within a virtual box vm okay and i had the
cena bluetooth adapter plugged in and passed through over usb and then i actually had to compile better cap
from source because the one from apt doesn't have like ble the bly module or whatever for some reason
what the heck really yeah super i do that too i don't maybe i did that a while back i did you run
it from a docker container no i didn't i actually started playing around with it a little bit before
when i was attacking a different surface and i didn't get very far and i had to move on to something
else so i might have compiled it from source back when and just had it installed on my laptop but
interesting yeah i have um that my laptop runs i just dual boot windows and and ubuntu and that's
always worked really well for me because like at the end of the day i'm running ubuntu 99 of the time
and then you know that that other one percent of the time is when i'm not at home and want to game
which is like very very minimal very minimal time frame um so yeah that's how i i just plugged it
straight into my or actually my you know my laptop had had uh had just a built-in bluetooth chip and
just use that so that worked great yeah i'd imagine that most of the built-in bluetooth chips probably
can work but it i think it mostly has to do with the drivers that are installed for like mac and
windows specifically like they mentioned that cause those kinds of problems so probably just if you have
linux you can just give it a shot like if you have bluesy and it picks up your bluetooth chip or
whatever your your bluetooth adapter already then you're probably good to go solid um like i said
we're a little little little weak on the news this week there's only one one little thing i don't know
if you had anything but the only thing that i saw was this burp vps proxy did you see that i did not
this is i i saw that you posted it in the doc and that was the first that i'd heard of it yeah so it's
pretty much like it's a burp extension um and i i should i mean the guy on um the guy that has it on
on github is demand of um but somebody posted on twitter too i i ought to go find that that tweet and
give him a shout out but um it looks like my favorite type of burp plugin where it's just like
it does something complex but all you have to do is just take an api key and plug it in and then just
boom it's done right it's probably like one api call yeah it's it's great because so you know what
it what it's doing is is it supports a bunch of different providers it supports aws digital ocean
linode and you just drop your api key in there and it'll just spin up um a vps proxy for burp and go
you know go out there spin it up connect your burp to it so you're not constantly getting um
banned uh when you're when you're performing some testing so i feel like this is going to be really
helpful when you have one of those stupid targets that like bans you every two minutes and doesn't
help you get that fixed because that's ridiculous that's interesting so it's just for proxying your
burp traffic yeah yeah it looks like it yep uses a socks five proxy okay very interesting there is um
there's this other this reminds me of a similar tool called fireprox um yeah but that's that's for like
that's like for all of of the that that gives you a url to hit right i don't know so so my understanding
is that basically just like uses the um i think it uses lambda or something yeah it does basically
just rotate your ips so that you're not hitting it from the same ip for all your different requests
it's not lambda what is it uh it's not lambda you're right it's like ip gateway or something like
that yeah yeah there you go yeah we should yeah so it uses api gateways to um to basically give you
different ips for all your requests so that you don't get like a single ip band i'm not sure how
efficient it is or anything like that but that also might be a good option instead of having a whole
have an entire vps setup you could basically just have one of these instances and just like hit it hit
it hit it until you get ip band and then spin up another instance yeah this this definitely works
well if you've got something like a a setup where one host is blocking you you know specifically
and then you can just spin up a fire proxy url for that specific coast and then hit that
instead um and you'll you'll every request will come from a different ip um but if you're trying
to attack you know a target that has a bunch of different like you know apis that need to
inner work together and stuff like that then uh burp vps proxy might be better so that all of your
traffic is going through you know a vps and then you can kind of spin it up spin it down as you get
banned along the way yeah yeah but we'll link to both of those tools uh down below yeah all right that's
all i had for the for the pre pre-topic shit why don't i want to want to dump it or don't want to
dive right into it let's do it man let's let's get right into it um so get some water in you joel
because you're going to be doing some talk in this episode we are talking about uh dynamic mobile
hacking specifically with with frida um this is sort of a a sequel to the other mobile episode that
we've got which was episode number six um so if you haven't seen that feel free to check that out
there might be some um if you haven't seen that uh depending on your mobile knowledge you might be a
little bit lost but all right i'm gonna set the scene and then we'll jump right in so what we talked
about last time was a lot of the basics of of mobile stuff we talked about all the different
components um intense activities you know just kind of getting the our hands dirty in android stuff
um and so what what we kind of want to and but that was largely focused on understanding
how android is programmed and how we can read the code uh largely talking about static analysis
so in the field of mobile hacking there's you know two primary and and correct me if i'm missing anything
here joel but you know there's two primary approaches there's a static analysis where you
can you read through the code and you try to identify the volumes that way and there's a dynamic
analysis which is um you know you're you're using a tool like frida or you're actually getting
in the app and making stuff happen um and figuring out how the app works that way um and and so um the
dynamic analysis piece is kind of what i want to focus on today um but you know these two should be
used in conjunction right joel right right yeah so usually i end up using both whenever i'm doing
hacking like i'll probably start with some static analysis but yeah you really want to like figure out
what's going on within the app and some of those things are way too complex to try and
figure out just by reading source code and it's just simpler and easier to call it directly or
look at what it's doing with frida yeah for sure so um for those of us that aren't aren't familiar with
this so um dynamic analysis just give me like a a brief overview of what that looks like and how
we are able even to do that yeah so essentially dynamic analysis is just looking at or maybe
modifying or hooking parts of the app while it's running so it's happening dynamically it's not based
on um like you're not reading through the source code you might be to figure out where you're gonna
set your hooks but outside of that it's like you're it's while the app is running nice so so the app is
running so we've got the app on a phone or on an emulator right which what's your go-to in these
sort of situations 99 of the time emulator the only times i end up using a physical device so
like for example with the thing that we're working on for this upcoming live hacking event i will be
using a phone for at least part of it because it uses bluetooth to do the setup initialization process
and right now as far as i'm aware um there's no way to get like a functioning bluetooth within
the emulator the like pass through doesn't it doesn't work like that yeah um so there's no
real easy way to do it maybe you could do it on linux maybe you would have a little bit better
look i'm not sure maybe maybe the one the one time you see that that phone sitting right there
yeah i've already i've already got a i've already got a a um a free descript for you i'll toss it over
to you when you whenever you start looking at um at stuff but okay so you know we're using 99 of
the time using an emulator um what kind of emulator do you normally go to i i've got two that i'm aware
of i've got jenny motion and then i've also got um avd android virtual device thing the thing that
comes bundled with android studio do you use either of those yeah so i use the one that's bundled with
android studio um you don't have to get it through android studio you can download it just the android
sdk and it's called emulator that's like the name of the binary um and you can use it the same way you
can call it you can like create the abds you can do all that stuff it's just probably significantly
easier to do it through android studio mainly because android studio has the stuff for downloading
and managing the sdk packages so you can download like the latest android sdk you can download the
google play image for android o or whatever and then you can install that and create your emulator
and configure it and then later on if you want to run it just using the emulator command absolutely you
can yeah that makes sense i i literally every time it's so annoying if you try to do it through
android studio because you have to open android studio and then you've got to click the little
more options button and then you click you know the android virtual devices whatever and then it
launches up this other thing so you've got all these windows and if you close any of those windows then
it just closes everything and i'm like honestly i i think it used to be a lot easier back in the day
i think they started to over complicate it like recently now if you run an emulator it shows like an
integrated like window within within android studio it's like it doesn't like pop out anymore so if you
run just like emulator at and then like at your like abd or whatever like that's the syntax um it'll just
spawn up a new window like a like a qmu instance and you'll be nice perfect yeah i should do that because
i hate having all these windows open at once and if i close any of them then it just bloats up my desktop
so okay so you've got the you've got the um you've got the emulator up so let's say you went and
downloaded android studio you've got the avd um open ad avd select you know pixel 5 build build that
guy now we're rolling um and we're interacting with that uh virtual device via adb and then do you
normally like do you normally have one of those devices that has access to the play store and then just
go download the apk or do you normally like pull the apk from somewhere and then like push it to the
device using adb install yeah so it depends on what i'm doing and what the situation is
i'd say like especially if i'm using a physical device yeah i'll probably just download the apk because
lots of times it's feature gated so you might not even be able to download an apk that uses
ble if your phone doesn't register as having ble with the google play store yeah so if you're using
some of those like play store downloader tools you might run into issues actually trying to get that
apk if you your device doesn't have like the whatever the compatible features and i've just
found that you have to do it with like a physical device if you want to get it or you can find it online
yeah yeah i i um when i was downloading this app and and getting installed for the for the leg um
i i tried to install it on my main phone and then set it up on my main phone and then there's like some
weird incompatibility with my specific device that i have and this version of the app and it's if you like
dig deep into the like release notices on their their website it's like oh by the way if you have this
and this then you're just not gonna be able to use bluetooth and i'm like ah i like set up that whole
thing um and so yeah that's that's a little bit of a of a pain but yeah yeah i think i think uh i had
another you know device sitting in my in my closet or whatever and is it an old device yeah it is and
actually so i had to update it a little bit to get it to meet the right like apk level or something like
that and uh and yeah it was it was yeah so almost certainly the problem is that it has bluetooth but
it doesn't have bluetooth low energy and so it has bluetooth but not bile and it can't talk with bile
stuff i've had the same problem with older android devices that i can't use for bluetooth testing anymore
because they need bile specifically oh wow yeah no this was this was an old old device i've just got like a
little like actually it's right here it's like this little it's supposed to be like a little
uh you know cable management thing i just have like a little label on it that just i know exactly
is that is that from is that from github is it from github let me see i we definitely got it at one
of the live hacking events yeah i think it was yeah i think it was from github actually i put it over the
i have the label over the place where i got it from so i have no idea but yeah yeah i think i have the
same one though it helps to it helps to have a bunch of you know old phones around when you're
doing mobile testing though because sometimes you'll have those sort of weird incompatibilities right
i just have a stack of phones in my drawer it's crazy let me see your phone drawer um
uh so um anyway okay so we've got the we've got the app running on an emulator we've got um
so then i you know you said we're doing this alongside with with uh static analysis so we're
opening up the app in like so okay so also let me let me ask refresh my memory what do you do
with uh jad you you unzip apk and then you decompile all the the dex files with with jad and then you
open that up in vs code is that right no not even i use i use apk tool to extract uh basically the
decoded resources yeah and the dex files yep and so now you've got small e right not not dex right and
then i use jadex to only compile source and not not the resources and out put that into the same folder
so like i feed them both the apk so i feed apk tool the apk to like decompile everything right but
like not pull out somali and all that kind of stuff and then i use jadex with the same apk
to have it decompile only the source code because i think jadex also does like resource decoding or
something but i prefer apk tools over that and then i'll also feed jadex apk and i'll have it output
into a full like the same folder in the source folder so so jadex jadex if you pass it in apk
then it will go ahead and it yeah it does dexter jar and everything okay okay okay i was i was wanting
to do it the joel way when i i did this last one i was like all right you know what i'm gonna get it
together i'm gonna be cool i'm gonna use vs code like joel and i'm gonna like you know how to parse
the whole thing the commands that i use yeah and like the specific arguments and stuff yeah but i just
you know i i always literally i just open it all up in jadex gui and and the search
functionality is kind of shit in that though so it's like you know not sure if that's the right
move but um it gets the job done part of the time okay it's especially nice if you don't want to like
have it all on your disk right yeah like if you just want to open a jar file or something and you
don't want to have to have a million java files on your on your c drive or whatever then you can just use
jadex gui okay so the setup now is we've got an emulator we've got the apk loaded onto the emulator
we've got our source code in front of us and vs code or jadex or whatever we're using and then um
now we want to start doing some dynamic analysis one of the most common use cases for dynamic analysis
is uh ssl pinning bypass right so talk to me a little bit about how that works and then you've got a
script somewhere which i will try to find while you're talking that does universal bypasses right
yeah so basically cert pinning like in a nutshell is base is the device verifying the certificate that
is coming back from the server okay so if you think about how proxying works especially for proxying
tls or http traffic your burp proxy you your system has trusted that the the ca the burp like certificate
authority cert which is going to issue new certificates to sign all your different requests
and because you've trusted it at a system level it's fine and you can proxy your traffic through burp but
if you weren't chrome would throw up probably be throwing yeah you know certificate errors just by
default certificate pinning settings yeah exactly now by default checking set i guess just certificate
validation right this isn't necessarily pinning it's just normal certificate validation over https
yeah this is at like a system level this is like normally your system is going to check that the
cert that's signing the traffic is what it should be and it's a valid cert and it's not self-signed
and all that kind of stuff right right right so if by default if you were to like install the
certificate on your android phone you would probably be able to get like some apps through there you
would run into the same issues you would run onto a pc if you were trying to proxy without or with a
certificate like for the most part it would work but certain apps a lot of apps honestly implement this
thing called certificate pinning which is where inside the app yeah inside the app they say these
are the specific these are the the specific sha 256 or whatever hash this is the specific hash of the
certificate that it should be coming back from the server and if it doesn't have that hash then reject the
request and it'll basically drop the connection and it'll fail you'll see it in burp it'll say like
you know tls verification failed or certificate uh verification failed or something like that
and so what you have to do is you have to bypass that verification you either have to tell it that
every certificate is okay or you just have to remove that verification step entirely
there are a couple different like core like http libraries that are very commonly used so before we go
into that i'm going to try to summarize it like like i was five here okay sure so by default https is the
thing that keeps our communication with the server secure right and um the way that that works is by
having a certificate presented by the server side um that says hey i am whoever you know whoever they're
claiming to be and that certificate is signed by a certificate authority um that's like the the big
guy that we all trust saying hey uh you know this guy really is this guy and we can validate that
cryptographically because there's a really smart five-year-old we're talking to here um we can validate
that no um we can validate that cryptographically um by using uh like because our our device has a set
of cas that we we trust and we can tell whether that signature was actually signed by the ca versus
by joe schmo and so um that's how normal https works now when we are installing a device you know a certificate
or when we're trying to you know see https traffic on an android device we have to install burp or whatever
intermediate proxy you're using https certificate their ca certificate on our device to say hey by the way we
also trust burp and burp just says hey i'm whoever the heck i want to be and just you know gives you a
valid certificate for every every person you know coming through and that is how you can sort of decrypt
that traffic as from a middleman perspective right right and again the main distinction between
certificate validation and like the standard certificate validation and certificate pinning that's happening
here is that certificate pinning says specifically only these certificates are allowed for the traffic that
i'm trying to send like i'm trying to talk to this api i should only be getting this certificate back or from
this ca back and if you're using burp that's not going to be the case so you have to change it at an
app level not at a system level you have to do both actually yeah so so what i just explained there was
normal certificate validation now we install the burp certificate on the android phone there's a million
tutorials out there to do that now the phone trusts burp right yep and if and if um the app that we're using
relies on the phone to do this validation then we're gucci everything's fine we can see the traffic
we can decrypt ssl it's it's it's perfect but and you can test that just like go to example.com like
hdps example.com and see if your phone throws a certain error okay so we've got that but then these
tricky developers are going to try to trip us up here by adding an extra layer on top of that and saying okay
not only are we going to validate the certificates you know trusted at the system level or whatever
we're also going to say that if the certificate presented is different than this specific certificate
they and they put you know the hash for that in the code then freak out and don't send any messages
alert alert attackers hacking us right right okay solid so that's that's ssl certificate pinning
it's a pain in the butt man it really is it's a pain in the butt um so yeah i'm glad we can figure
out how to get past that yeah so you mentioned the script um i talked about this i did uh i did a long
like interview with ben um the homsec and we talked about like mobile hacking and stuff and we also did
like a large blog post for hacker one yeah about android hacking and in that blog post i linked to
this free to script i think at the end um and this is basically my go-to script as well uh that's the
same script that i use for 99 of apps i almost never have an issue with it unless it's a custom
implementation of cert pinning somewhere um so basically it just looks for a lot of the really
common certificate pinning libraries that exist out there okay http um like the built-in like
android like trust kit trust manager trust kit yeah exactly and it hooks like all of them at as
basically a lower level as possible so that generically speaking it can hook most cases and
it can stop cert pinning in most cases including at like a system level or if you're using like the
trusted certs xml or whatever like the new way that they do it with android i'm reading through the
script and one one of the things here is trusty trust manager is that is that is that you naming
stuff or is that yeah it's a trusty trust manager trust manager it's very trusty oh my gosh lovely okay
i don't know why that hits me so different right now trusty trust manager all right solid so we
we'll link that we'll link that in the in the description um definitely check out joel's script
and okay so hopefully if they're using one of these default you know ssl pinning libraries then you can
just run this this free okay so we can just run this free to script we're going to explain how to do that
in a second or talk a little bit about that but run this free to script and then ssl pinning should
disappear and boom you should be able to proxy the traffic right pretty much yeah that's that's what
i've been doing with your script for the past couple years and it's been great and i can confirm that it
does work let's say i'll say 90 of the time you know because there are some weird some weird fringe
ones out there which i'll talk about if if we get to the report section later in this in this
conversation i'm not sure if we will with how long we're going right now but um yeah okay so now okay
we we set it all up burp certificates installed you know we're seeing some traffic go through
you know in like our normal android browser whatever you know if we open up the browser we
go to google and it it doesn't throw a certificate error but when we open up the app it says error
connecting to the server you know this yeah is what it says okay so we've got that's a good indicator
that there's some cert pinning there what's the next step so if i'm trying to figure out like
custom cert pinning for example one of the first places that i'll look okay okay so let's say let's
before we know whether it's it's custom cert pinning or not i mean do you just go right down the rabbit
hole and try to find custom cert pinning or do you run the free to script in general you know right
off the bat and then if it doesn't work then you try to go find it um yeah i mean usually i'll just
try it out of the box if it doesn't work then i'll run my free to script if it still doesn't work
then i assume it's custom pinning okay so so walk me through running the free to script do we just like
how does that work yeah so free to involves basically two main parts there's free to server
and free to cli so free to cli runs on i'll call it the host that's like your laptop or your pc or
whatever right where where you're like running your scripts from and all that kind of stuff and then
the server runs on the device or on your emulator um so you download free to server from github from their
releases uh they have regular releases you want to download the one that's specifically it should be like
free to dash server dash version dash android this is the thing i always get wrong so when i'm downloading
that hold on let me let me pull up the the frida so i'm going to github going to frida going to
releases right and then they got this like list of all of these yeah and make sure you expand it
yeah so frida so if i search for server there's there's okay and then there's specifically so it says
free to server and then the version and then we've got android and share your screen oh yeah hold on
let me see if i can do that we have this fancy software no way this is nuts frida let me see if
i can find the right tab here there we go this guy right here right look at that we are in the next
wow okay that is so hard to read i don't know what i'm saying to say there this is this is the future
um this is the future let me just zoom in so um yeah so we've got this right free to server
now we've got free to free to server for android arm arm 64 x86 x86 64 all of these how the heck do we
know which one to download and which one to put on our um you know device and it has to be compatible
with our actual um frida that's installed on our computer too right so how do we determine that
yeah so i always just install the latest version of both and that will remove any of that version
confusion whether or not it's compatible and all that kind of stuff just install the latest version of
both if if you're ever unsure uh for the architecture it's the same as like with linux so you'd run
you name dash a on on the device over adb and it'll tell you what the architecture of the device is
um if it's like a arch or if it's uh x86 or if it's uh x86 64 or whatever most of the time you're gonna
see either arm maybe titled arm v7 or b7 l okay um army a eabi or you'll see
x86 or you'll see arm 64. okay and if and if it's most of the time gonna be one of those if you're
running it in an emulator it's normally x86 right it's normally probably x86 64. okay but yeah it's
going to be either x86 or x86 64 unless you're on like a mac m1 or m2 that has an arm chip right and
then it'll right so it's going to be if you're running it on on an emulator it's going to be the same
architecture as the as your cpu unless you're explicitly emulating a different architecture
right you can run an arm yeah it's just crazy slow yeah okay gotcha so you go through the full
step and install frida on your free to command line on your computer and free to server on the thing
every single time your boy is a little bit lazier than joel yeah and so every time yeah i usually just
like have it on the device and then if it doesn't work then i'll like update them both okay so i have
some helper scripts and stuff yeah like i mentioned there's two steps there's free to server on the
device and then the second part is free free to cli on your computer so on your host you're going to
use pip and you're going to pip install free to dash tools and that will install the free to cli
on your computer so that you can interface with the free to server that's running on the device
nice what i always do i'll throw this little little tip out there is i always go to my command line
and run frida dash dash version and then get the version and then go to the releases and download
that version for the server and then throw that on the device so that i don't you know have any version
mitchmashes because they don't like that um uh so yeah but that's probably the better way to do it
yeah so for on the device there's a couple like main things that you want to be aware of yeah um so
the first is generally you want the device to be rooted for an emulator you can easily root
them with this tool called root avd we'll link it it's super great it will basically root the image
itself so that you have su and all that kind of stuff uh you can get root over you can just su to
get root on adb and it makes everything super easy yeah straightforward okay so quick question about
that because i normally just run adb what is it adb root yeah did i have that automatically installed or
what is that only for images are you using getting motion no i'm using um i'm using avd
avd yeah so i think that's that's what gets enabled when you when you do that you can i think
you unless you do adb root or maybe you can just well it only does it on some of the emulators because
like they're on some on the ones that have like the play store oh yeah yeah that's what it is okay so
you actually can root the ones with the play store yeah yeah oh that's what i mean yeah so use root
abd to root the play store images yeah so so that's a good distinction there are two there's like the
the like default builds i think they're like there's like i forget what they call it google api or
something and there's play store version right and so the play store versions have google play store
services they have the play store app they have all the google like built-in like uh google app
services all that kind of stuff installed already that lets you download apps and it's basically like
default android if you use just the google api's one it's like very very bare bones it doesn't have
google play services it doesn't have the google play store doesn't have like any of that kind of
stuff the problem is that a lot of apps rely on google play services so most of the time you need that
it's really hard to install that on just like a stock google api image they call it a production build
right so if you were to run a google play image like emulator image and you were to try to do adb
root it would say adb root is not enabled for production builds and that's because they consider
the google play build to be a production build right so you have to use root avd to root that image
so that you can have it you can have su access while you have like play store and everything
enabled otherwise yes you can run adb root and then everything you run through adb will be root by
default gotcha okay that is that is a tidbit that i did not know that i've struggled with in the past
because some of these things really do require the play store um pieces and if you don't have root
then you can't run frida very easily so then i have to go the other route which we'll talk about
later hopefully if we have time which is the um the patching the apk route um but before we get
down that rabbit hole so you know we get root on the android device and then we uh get free to
server on there how do you do you just normally just how do you get root i use adb push um so like
you download the server on your host on your computer and then you adb push the file to uh data local
data slash local slash temp that's the go to directory it's a it's a unique balance on the
android file system because of the way that permissions work across different folders it's
a place where you can set things as executable and execute them nice and download stuff and you have
right permission and it's a temporary folder so basically some things will stay in there but it's
used by the system for other temp stuff that gets auto removed so it's kind of a nice place if you read
all the docs most of the time they'll tell you to put it there so push it into data local temp
you're going to need to set it executable so ch mod it either uh i think 755 is what they tell you
to do you could probably plus x that's what i do but just yeah 755 or plus x and then make sure you
disable se linux as you linux is enabled by default on android it's going to cause problems with like
cross-process communication all that kind of stuff that frida needs to be able to do so uh set enforce
spaces zero that'll turn off se linux and you can type get enforce to check what your se linux status
is it'll say either enforcing or permissive um so you want it to be permissive nice i i don't know that
i've ever done that so maybe i think maybe some of the other images have like some of the images that
are not the play store images have it disabled by default or something like that for debug purposes or
i'm not sure yeah i'm not sure like sometimes you run into it more than others but it'll be pretty
obvious when it's an se linux error and you need to disable it gotcha okay so then you've got the
server running you've got the client running now the connection server's not running yet okay so yeah you
need to run the server so like data slash data such local such temp slash free to server the in the newer
versions of frida there's a dash capital d for daemon mode that runs it in the background automatically so
it used to be that you'd put an ampersand after it and just do it like that as a background process now
you can just do slash dash capital d and it will run it in daemon mode it has that built in and now
your frida server is running now on your host if you type frida dash ls dash devices you should see
your frida server like instance basically listed there showing that it's running it's connected it
sees the device you're ready to go frida dash ls devices solid and that's that just validates like
what what devices are connected to to freedom okay so then you've got your server up then you can do
the fun stuff um now you're ready to run the script so if you're using the cert pinning script for example
yeah typically what i would run is frida dash capital u for usb which basically tells it to
use like a plugged in device not the host machine because you can run frida like on processes on your
host machine so you want to distinguish i want to do this on a connected device um so dash u for usb
and then dash l and i'll point that to my script path dash l for load script and then uh typically
dash f or dash n depending on whether i'm attaching so dash f is for spawning a new instance of an app
it'll launch it and then attach it at the same time versus dash n is for attaching to an existing
running instance of an app so if for an example the app crashes on launch if frida's attached which
sometimes happens then you might need to launch the app then attach frida to the running instance and
you'll be good to go solid okay i love how you just pulled all that out of your head i every single
time i do this i'm like getting into uh you know my my command line and then i'm like typing frida and
then i just press up up up up up up and then and then inevitably i don't find it and then i i resort to
you know when you're really desperate history pipe grep frida you know and then you can see the whole list
do you use uh do you use fcf fuzzy fun i don't actually and i i have that's really good i have um
i have fish i i use fish as my primary um you know cli um which i'd love i love fish but also let me
say i a little bit regret it because obviously the syntax is different than bash right so if you do
something like zsh it's it's intercompatible but now all of my scripts that i've been writing for the
past you know a couple years are in fish and so if i ever try to like switch computers into like
you know i i've seen you know we all surely you can chat gpt that come on yeah yeah oh that's a good
idea that's a good use for it um but uh yeah you know whenever i'm trying to like jump onto a server
and trying to like pull down my config you know none of my scripts work by default because they're all fish
and it's like uh what the heck yeah i really like zsh but fcf it's really good it's called fuzzy find
or fuzzy finder and uh it's basically like a better version of control r or like history search on
terminal um and it also works for like finding files on your file system if you just type fcf it'll look
in your local file system and you can it's like basically fuzzy finding right so you can type like
parts of your command you could type like frida and then you could type maybe an app that you've run
before or like dash n or something and it'll fuzzy search across the across your commands like not just
exact search like how reverse searches um and it's really really good solid i just added that to the
notes for the uh for the description that looks super helpful they've got something a little bit
similar to that with with fish by default but yeah that seems that seems better um okay anyways so
joel knows his command line flags i do not know my command line flags that's that's the the tldr of
that i've run a free descriptor two in my day yeah i can see it i can see it um okay so we've got
the server running we so when you say dash f or dash n you're launching a process so normally what that
looks like is you are giving it the package name right for the for the um yeah for launch you give it the
package name and for attach you give it the app name that's also a new thing it used to be that it was the
package name for both um if you do free to dash ps space dash u again dash u for like usb or connected
device then that will list the processes that free to seize and it'll show you like if you have a running
app it'll show you the app name right it won't show you the package and then for the rest of them it
should show like the package so that's kind of how you'll know um but if you want to that's like one
thing that you do need to either look up or be aware of is if you want to spawn an app and you only
know the name of the app you're gonna have to find the package name yeah that's not hard to do but
just be aware yeah no that that's that's gotten me recently because i was like why is this frida
command not working i copied and pasted from the last time i used frida and then it was like yeah okay
so there's some differentiation there i love how you are like a walking frida documentation i dig that um
so okay so we've got it running we've run the script um you know decrypts the the the uh the ssl
sir pinning happy day now we're able to you know use the app um we can talk about custom ssl
sir pinning implementations but um the other thing that i want to go i want to jump backwards a little
bit so in this situation this assumes that we are using a rooted device um because you can't just have
other processes hooking into other processes if they're not rude right so um what about the situations
joel when you cannot use a rooted device for whatever reason like the app flips out if you're on a rooted
device um what is your what is your approach to that yeah so it depends on how they're doing their checks
typically um we we did mention like you can patch the apk so that is an option um there are ways to get
frida within a an apk through patching essentially you put the native a free to native library into the app
you re-sign the app or you edit the smally code to load that library which will be the same as launching frida server
but within just that process right so instead of being system-wide frida it's i patch this apk to load frida
frida specifically and it has frida but nothing else does um and then you can attach to it like you would
with frida server but it's just that single instance of the app um you can do that uh or you can just
edit the smally code and you can you know make changes recompile it resign it install it run it and
that could be your workflow it's just a lot slower it's a lot more tedious there are definitely cases
i think most often i would say like banking apps money apps those have the most stringent type of
security policies that you have to have for device security so it like is the device a secure environment
essentially like uh mainly for like protecting people's money and identity theft and all that kind of
stuff just the types of stuff that you can do through mobile banking apps and mobile money apps nowadays
are equivalent to walking into the bank so they have to be very very secure about that type of stuff
they want to make sure your phone's not compromised all that all that jazz right so those are probably
where you're going to run into a lot of these issues and they're going to be like complex type
of systems that are going to try and stop you from running on a rooted device they might be using
stuff like attestations that are going to be verified on the server side before you even log in
that is probably going to be the trickiest situation because attestation stuff is implemented at like
an os system level by google uh either through the play integrity app uh play integrity api or the
safety net apis both of those are like really hard to get around and bypass and spoof um just because
of where they're located they're like lower than frida so um and they're like very complex native
library driven systems that are hard to intercept so it's just like it's not an easy task to overcome
however generally speaking you'll probably be able to get around most things with either
just straight up free scripts or manually patching the app yeah that's a good point so just if if it's
if for example you know you run into a situation where you don't
if you run into a situation yeah yeah um you run into a situation where you
are you know the app is like hey you're rooted don't don't do that you know um i don't know why
my app's a cat your cat is a mad yeah yeah exactly um but you know then we can the first approach i'd
imagine is let's just disable that so you know you go into this the code um in vs vs code if you're cool
jadex gui if you're not and then um you you find the place where that root function you know that root
check is being done a lot of times i do that via um taking the error code and then just kind of working
backwards figuring out what string.xml that that is and then you know figuring out where that string.xml is
located in the actual java code and then you know narrowing down what function is doing this um
this check and then there's normally a function that just returns a boolean that's like
uh you know is rooted true is rooted false and then you can just overwrite that um with with uh
frida and um you know change that false to a true or change it to always return you know false if
it is rooted you know that sort of thing um right and that in for those of you that that
are a little bit intimidated by that task if you look at joel's um uh ssl on pinner script
um you'll see these functions uh these these actually uh assignments variable assignments i'm
gonna i'm looking at the one on line 34 here certificate pinner dot check dot overload dot
implementation what he's doing there is he's he's selected the specific certificate pinner class on line
33 okhtp3 dot certificate pinner and then he's selected the check function and selected
the overload um for that because there's multiple check functions depending on the parameters
um that takes a string and list and then he's taking that implementation and overwriting it with
this function that he's defined right after there which is essentially just saying we we
intercepted http3 or okhtp3 and then um you know we're just returning saying everything's good
right so that's how easy it is to overwrite functions just arbitrary functions inside the code
um right yeah so the way that this check works typically it would throw an exception
so that's why you're just doing a return typically the way that i would check is it's a void it's a
void return it doesn't actually return anything it just executes and if there's a certificate error it
throws an exception which which would get caught by whatever's calling it so instead you just exit out
immediately there's no error no problem keep going no error no problem no error no problem um okay
we're we're in a goofy mood today man um okay so go ahead going back to going back to um the
using frida on an injured without root um there's a article that i wanted to call out that's like my
go-to article for this that i just like i remember very vividly when i started learning about this um
this article by a person called i cause i k o z i love that guy yeah um and so let me let me pull
up his twitter as well i don't know if it's just i cause yeah it's just i cause um and he does an
article called using free on android without root very very apt name um and he walks through you know
the basics of how to do it and you know in detail doing exactly what you would what you would need to
do so that one's great if you really want to understand what's going on um i when i was first
learning i went ahead and manually patched the smally code which is kind of kind of a tricky
process um but it was good to understand what was happening and then ever since i have been using
this tool called objection um which i'll also link in the description uh an article by netspi n-e-t-s-p-i
um and let me just pull that up right here it's it's written by cody wass um and it's four ways to
bypass android ssl verification and certificate pinning is the title um and uh just really good information
there on how to use objection and some other ways to get around certificate pinning so i'll link both
of those excellent resources um like joel said you probably shouldn't have to do this too much
um but if you do um it's good to be able to do it and it allows you to get some around some really
some really tricky uh situations so yeah yeah yeah objection is pretty good um it's like i i refer to
it as kind of a multi-tool so like multi-tools if you've ever had a multi-tool like there's like a
the knife version of a multi-tool it's like you know it's pretty good at a lot of things but it's not
going to be the best knife it's not going to be the best pliers it's not going to be the best
screwdriver right so that's where you're going to want to dive into individual tools that really
specialize in the specific areas but as a general all-around tool that can do like a lot of different
things it's really good for that yeah solid that makes sense so check out objection if you're in that
sort of situation okay so let me look at the doc real quick because we're we're getting we're getting
long here on time um okay so we have a route today let's say let me give you a hypothetical we've got a
root detection function in there um did did the the flow that i described you know tracing it back
through the strings and that sort of thing did that resound with you is there any other tips and tricks
you have for like finding where the the functions are in the code that do the thing that you're trying
to make not happen yeah so i mean what you described is generally the first place i would look okay like
see is there's is there an error being like on the screen that i can search within the app find a string
find where it's referenced in the code trace that back see where it's thrown see where what's causing
this pinning etc right yeah trace just trace it back from like an unknown thing that is probably the
first thing that i would try if i can't get anywhere with that i would probably check logcat
um yeah that's the other one with adb logcat there are a couple different flags you can throw on logcat
that will let you cert like filter by specific like a specific app or a specific pid so you'll only see
logs for like just that running app which makes it a lot cleaner and a lot easier to read and
understand what's going on um i'll check logcat because logcat will have it might have an exception
thrown it might have an error message that's related like similarly that it might not be shown
like on the screen but it might be in the logcat that's showing either a traceback or an exception or
some kind of log message that i can also search for in the code um and then if that doesn't work i'll
start searching for generic terms i'll start searching for pin pinning certificate uh maybe
even like ssl or verification or something like that and i'll just look and see if i still am not
finding anything uh then i'm just gonna like start digging through package files that are related to
the like you know it's like you just gotta keep going it's gonna get grindy after a certain point yeah i
imagine so and and um yeah i mean most of the time that should get you there the only other time that
i've kind of run into a situation where i was god i cannot find this function um is you know sometimes
those these functions can be in native libraries right um so talk to me a little bit about this concept
of native libraries and how it makes our life more difficult as an android tester sure yeah so native
libraries are basically portions of the android code base that are written in native c or c plus plus
so it's like uh say you have this hash signing or like for a legitimate use case it would be something
that you want to run faster than a canon job sure right or take advantage of like native c plus plus level
bindings or certain c plus plus libraries or something like that you would write it into c plus plus and
then when you build your app you would get out a dot so file right similar to what you have on linux
it's just like a dynamic like linkable library and it gets loaded from the java side using system
load library and it's it typically the bindings within the app within that library so there'll be a
a method called jni on load there's a whole set of methods they're called jni methods java native
interface and basically they define like how jni libraries work so when a jni when you call like
system.load library it will automatically call jni on load when it loads the jni right okay and so from
there a lot of things will happen it'll do some uh mapping from function names within the c plus plus to
function names within the java so you'll see in the java code for example in the java code base you'll
see what looks like this is getting a little technical you'll see what looks like an abstract
class definition where it will have functions that are listed but they have no bodies and they'll be
defined as native within like you know native void whatever like native string right is that a
is that a decorator in in job what is that no no it's it's like one of the like precursor keywords that
that says like you know where you put like void or like public static right it's native right and so
you're saying like this is a native function and in your c plus plus say you had com dot example
dot my class sure and then you had a function called like do something right okay
in c plus plus your function would be java underscore com underscore example underscore my class underscore
do something and that's how it knows to associate the abstract class to the the implementation which
is in c plus plus correct and it has to have like a similar function signature and everything it'll throw
errors if it doesn't sure um alternatively and this is where things also get trickier is if they don't do that
they can do it through j and i on load there's this thing called register natives um and this flew
under the radar for me for a while until i i figured out what it was and basically it lets you register a
native method to a specific uh signature like in the same way that you would name it by that string you
can say oh this string should actually be associated with this pointer i'm seeing that and call this pointer
right and so that means that they can obfuscate the native library to like kingdom come they can do
whatever they want with it they can hide those strings super super hard like the signature string
for example they can have like custom string encoding and decryption that results in that string and then
all they have to do there's you know one assembly instruction in there that's calling out and registering
the natives and pointing it to that pointer and you're gonna have to figure out which pointer it is
or which functions actually doing this stuff yeah there are a couple things that can help with this
um i'm blanking on like what they are specifically but there are there are plugins for ghidra and for
ida that both will help map the j and i calls so they have basically loaded up the j and i header that has the
offsets for like all the structs and then it will rename the references and say oh it's calling
on load here or it's calling register natives or it's calling get class um because there's like
but this is also how you would for instance like if you want to use a java string class you have to do it
through j and i native bindings so you do like get class and then you get an instance of like a c plus
pointer that points to that class and it you know it's it's java that is a very convoluted process
there okay so i'm gonna try to i'm gonna try to simplify it um so you know normally the the normal
situation is we've got this this class this abstract class and the function names are appropriately named
in the native library and then it just kind of shoves those implementations into the abstract class just
like you would do you know in normal you know object-oriented programming but yeah and that's the
simplest case yeah and that's pretty much the only case that i've run into that i that i could find
but also i was going to talk about this other case that i i uh i couldn't figure so maybe actually
that was what was happening i should have called you in this scenario because i had this one time
i was like man i cannot patch this and i actually ended up all i needed to do was change one letter in
a header so that i could overwrite it instead of you know and i actually ended up literally patching
the native library i literally just opened it up in a hex header and like searched for the string and
like replaced one of the characters in the string and it changed it and it worked beautifully but shout out
to space raccoon for that awesome idea um but then maybe it could have been the register natives thing
that was that was getting me there so that's that's that's hella complex um
i don't even know what i want to ask you so it's super dense yeah this is the thing with native
libraries is like generally native libraries are like it requires a whole separate skill set right
because you have to be familiar with assembly code you have to be familiar with like pointers and like
c plus plus and like j and i which is like a whole other thing um and so it does definitely take like
a lot of like extra like effort and resources i wouldn't really recommend unless you need it to like
dive into all of that unless it's something that's really interesting to you but it's one of those
things that i've kind of only like learned out of necessity yeah um and it's like a very like
complex and it's super hard to like reverse engineering and like come at it the other way from
solid so i'm looking at this thing here the only other thing that i wanted to pick your brain on
just on my on my hit list here was like okay um let's say that i i've had this scenario happen a
couple times where i was like okay i found the function i need to overwrite and like for some reason
it's not letting me overwrite it in in frida um there's there's this thing i think i think i messaged
you and i think we came up with the conclusion let me see if i can find this app or this uh yeah here
it is so what we ended up doing was java.perform and then we put the the function call inside of it
and then what i ended up doing was having to run set interval which is javascript function which runs
a function at a set interval very aptly named um and and then you know it would run that function
again and then whenever that function got to find it would just overwrite it overwrite it overwrite
overwrite it why is that happening and why why do i have to use this set interval function to
overwrite the specific function this is a very specific question yeah so we were talking about
this and it was in a native library right yeah the function yeah so the reason is as i mentioned
native libraries don't get initialized until you load them so you have to call system.load library
in order to initialize the native library within the java context if you don't do that and you try
and call it it's going to be like i don't know what you want me to call like it doesn't know it has
to be loaded up into memory so you essentially had to wait for system.load library to be called by the
app before you could hook that function and that's why you had to keep doing it on a timer until it
got loaded up once it got loaded up then you can hook it solid okay so the native library had to be
loaded up and that wasn't happening until later point after the free descript is running so when the
free descript there's like a little race condition there right when the frida would run then it would
be like yeah what the heck this function doesn't exist and then afterwards it would get to find
so when i when i went ahead and stuck it in the the set interval and put like a try catch statement in
there then it would say like okay you know nope not there nope not there yeah yep they loaded it
now i'm going to override it is that accurate exactly salt yep okay cool um well actually that leads
right quite well into my report you down to jump into that now you got anything else you want to say on
on uh you know dynamic i did i did have two things that i that i wanted to mention yeah actually one
thing because i think one of them we mentioned i think we already talked about proxying over usb
with adb rumors yeah in a different episode yeah i've been using that really dynamic yeah that's been
helpful yeah that yeah not really a dynamic hacking thing but certainly quite useful especially since we
talked about hacking on physical devices another thing with physical devices and this is the other the
other thing there's a tool that was made by jenny motion uh or jenny mobile i guess is the company
it's called uh scr copy s-c-r-c-p-y um and it's basically just a tool that lets you display your
android like a physical device screen you just plug it in over usb and you can view and control the
screen on your computer so you don't have to like pick up your phone and stuff it also does like
clipboard transferring which is super nice uh you can just like click and drag stuff it has the buttons
it's like it's great it's like in between android emulator but physical device makes it a lot easier
for doing a lot of testing for those of you listening on the podcast i'm just sitting here with my jaw
dropped right now this is super cool so is this super awesome like it just takes it just mirrors the
screen onto your computer and lets you dude that's so helpful oh my gosh and and is it hard to set up i mean
can i just use this with avia air like the the android studio i don't have to use like jenny mobile's
thing do i no no no it's like it's a fully separate package they even have here you can get
it with apt for this no way really what it oh my gosh apt installs scur copy yeah screen copy i guess
is what it's short for but yeah on mac you can use brew they have install docs on in the readme on
there on the repo but yeah it's a super useful tool i i use that like nine times out of ten when
i'm using a physical device just because it's a pain to have to like pick it up and have it connected
somewhere that i can touch the screen and all that kind of stuff and all the copy pasting and all that
whatever dude that is a game changer right there i'm installing that right now oh my gosh that's going
to be real cool okay i i'm putting that in the show notes let me let me get that any of you guys
who do mobile hacking on a general or on a uh normal basis that is oh you got it nice you beat me to it
um that is a game changer right there dang it joel why didn't you tell me about that before man this
is i was thinking about it but we had already moved on when we were talking about the physical versus
emulator thing yeah we moved on to jadex and i was like i'll just write this down and
it was like on my sticky note until the end well i'm glad i checked in with you again rather than just
jumping right into the reports because that would have missed out on that juicy tidbit um
yeah so all right so adb reverse that's in episode six um and then you know this scr copy yes screen
copy nice to to display your physical device on your on your host more bangers from joel guys frick i love
that okay um all right so let me jump into the report for the day i was looking on hacker one um activity
stuff trying to find you know a disclosed report that we could kind of talk through with frida
but there's pretty much nothing which was really surprising to me yeah it's really interesting i
think part of it is that frida scripts are kind of like special secret sauce a lot of the time a lot
of people either they have their own script suites or maybe they over time they they have like
figured something out and they don't want to just put it in like code basically that anybody
can download and know like oh this is how you do that um so i've tried to push away from a lot of
that like by publishing my cert pinning script and that kind of stuff that's kind of like a big
long-standing problem in my opinion with uh most of like the mobile hacking space is that a lot of it
is like secret knowledge that uh people have like built up over time and they don't really talk about
it they just like show the cool results which is really cool but um it doesn't really help build
like a strong mobile security community that can like expand and other people can learn all that kind
of stuff so i might try to be as public as i can about a lot of this stuff yeah dude i definitely
appreciate that so thanks for for sharing the sauce there um let me just talk through this report really
quickly um so this one was a little bit interesting one uh this is a high um and uh this is an ato
on a specific service that i can't name but there was this um service where several people would come
together and they would help provide care for another individual um and uh the way that this
service sort of worked is um well it was primarily done through an app um and that app uh was using
ssl pinning but wasn't just using any ssl pinning it was using custom ssl pinning which is actually we
didn't get super much into that so i'm glad we have this report so we can talk through it so i was
using uh you know i fired up frida through joel's universal d uh you know unpin at it and uh it it
wasn't allowing me to see the traffic still i was still seeing in one of the ways you can tell that
you're you're not seeing um the traffic is if you go to burp and you go to the let me just pop burp
open right now yeah if you go to dashboard and you go to event log um down there it'll say client failed
to negotiate a tls connection um and that will tell you that you know sir pinning is is sort of in
place um and and you also see some stuff in the app as well um and so uh the uh situation here was that
that they had a custom uh surpinning implementation and um there was a function that i'm trying to i'm
trying to say it without without actually giving away too much of details anyway there's there's a
function called tls config um and uh it was inside of or there's a class called tls config and inside of
that was a a function called set verify server and this was you know so this is a classic and it returned to
boolean right so this is this is perfect for um just kind of what we were talking about it's just a
it's a simple simple fix you just find that class and find that function and then you just overwrite
that function with your own implementation that returns false now here is some big some big brain
tips okay um and this is one of the reasons i i forgot about this before this is one of the reasons why
i do use jadex gui as a uh as my you know gui of choice for auditing android apps inside of jadex gui
you can right click on a function and hit copy as free to snippet and this will literally take the
the function class take everything just give you this beautiful free to snippet and then you can just
drop it right into a script and run it and it will overwrite that function and give you like logs
with that function when that function gets called sorry that is pretty neat that's that's pretty
freaking cool right so i i did that and um put that in there and i was seeing today okay it was
getting called and then i just went ahead and and overrode it with um uh you know set false
set to false um so that allowed me to see the traffic for the specific service which was under
under um audited because of this uh you know custom ssl pinning and um when i went into that that
traffic i saw one of the functions there was an impersonate function where these you know group of
people can help this other person do their job um by you know impersonating and like taking over their
um you know screen or whatever and in doing the action for them um whenever you see stuff like that
you should you should be you should be hearing the ching from the bounties uh because that is that is
normally very very hard to implement properly and um i was hoping that i could potentially just put in
uh you know any user's id and it would just let me you know impersonate that user wasn't the case but it
did allow me to put in the id of somebody on my like care team and then get the get the access token for
them so um the other people that are kind of working in the same scenario as me to help you know
this person do their job this other person do their job i could take over their accounts so then
we got arbitrary account takeover in that in that way um on those accounts and uh that was that resulted
in a in a high uh vulnerability and i would never have found it if i hadn't gone through that those
loops to um get rid of that ssl cert pinning and i have to say like sometimes it can feel really like
i just spent like five hours you know trying to bypass ssl pinning and stuff like that but just like
we talk about all the time with like getting access to scope or paying the extra 50 bucks to get
the premium feature or you know getting access to scope that other attackers aren't willing to go
through the effort to get access to or aren't willing to pay the money to get access to that
almost always produces amazing results so um taking it a little bit further bypassing that custom ssl
pinning implementation bypassing that root detection can often land you some pretty sick bounties even in
the http realm it doesn't necessarily have to be some crazy mobile bug but you know it can also just
be an http you know rest api bug as well yeah 100 a lot of that security through obscurity stuff happens
in the mobile space just because people don't look at mobile and people don't understand mobile and
people don't know how to get past some of the basic security measures that exist on mobile like
sir pinning and as a result they just put a lot of really crazy stuff behind that yeah yeah absolutely
so that's the that's the report i had um you got one you want to talk about joel yeah so this is this
is actually my first ever bug this is the first ever report i created on no way it was yeah this is um this
was at the h1702 2017 my first live hacking event my first bug bounty anything and uh one of the
targets was uber and they were like uh they were one they had put up a challenge that they had like
a specific couple of challenges and one of the challenges was to bypass uh the jailbreak detection
on their driver rep and i was like oh i can definitely do that i use free to all the time
yeah that like i could just hook a couple methods and so i spent all night like i i hadn't done any
like hacking ahead of time or anything like because i i was like super out of the loop on all this stuff
so i just like sat down and i i just like dug into it and i wrote up this like crazy long free to
script that hooked a bunch of different things and uh yeah i bypassed it and i actually got to do a
show and tell for that no way really again it was my my first live hacking event i was like i i had no
idea what was even going on i was like yeah so out of it i was so like what is all this who who is this
franz rosen guy dude well congrats because that's i mean getting to do a show and tell at your first
live hacking event is nuts um that's how you can tell you got some serious you know you're in the right
place um but yeah i will say i have seen a couple challenges like that where people will put like
you know if they have a mobile app in scope they're like hey if you can bypass our root detection we'll
give you you know a medium or something like that and i always eat those up man like i i i have
i'll just pull up my i've got more than this one i've yeah i've got plenty of guys that i've gotten
from from bypassing that really wow yeah most of the time the problem is that the the checks are on the
client side right so they're very trusting towards what the client is sending and they just assume
that the stuff that if the client has gotten that data that it's legitimate and you can either just
feed in fake data to the client or you can bypass those checks and make it look legitimate um and then
the server will trust a lot of that stuff and you've already proven impact wow that's crazy yeah so i've
got a couple of of those i've never been paid more than a medium for it um but apparently there's highs
out there to be gained and like like joel said there's pretty much you know it's it's almost
always possible right you know because there's there's um all of this code that's running on the
device is in your control if you're running on a rooted device um so you should be able to theoretically
go in there hook the right functions return the right values and bypass the whole thing so definitely
something to be on the lookout for there yeah cool i think that was it for me yeah this was a long
episode i know there was a lot of data condensed in here um but yeah i i hope that it was helpful
yeah for sure man it always is and um yeah i'm looking through here i think we hit most everything so
that's good we definitely we still have so much more to cover in mobile so there'll definitely be more
mobile episodes to come and and it seems like you guys really enjoyed the last one um so yeah we'll definitely
keep those keep those keep those coming at a at a pace where you can take some time digest all the
wisdom that that joel has imparted to us um and yeah become become better mobile hackers so is that
the pod i think that's the pod all right peace peace